but
today i am going to show you my six
billion dollar youtube house uh
setup tour
but first we gotta check out some other
youtubers setup and i'm gonna check out
some of you guys set up as well which
i'm excited about first we're gonna
check out dan tdm scene has changed a
ton since last time and since i've
started streaming his videos look really
good he has the camera really high up
which i don't like i like to speak down
to you guys if i if i if i had to choose
i would shoot all my videos like like
this
how's it going bros you feel
sorry he's got the nice camera quality
he's got that sparkle in his eyes that
makes it look like he's about to cry i
like that how do you get that dan he's
got the shure microphone a lot of people
have this microphone i think ken has it
too it's supposed to be really good uh
every youtuber in the mother has the go
xlr i refuse to buy that thing it's way
too big i'm not gonna buy that it's got
the sony a7 i have that too how is this
cable situation dan show us your cables
dan
this wall back here oh he's got a really
good setup it looks really nice it looks
cozy it looks like a really cozy setup i
really like it actually next we have
mkhb
hd envy scratch he's got that minimal uh
minimalist spirit i can tell the clean
cut not too much stuff going on i i like
that the cables
what are the cables
this is i don't understand you have this
setup worth like thirty thousand forty
thousand fifty thousand
i don't know maybe i'm exaggerating you
can't spend like 20 bucks and 20 minutes
to just like clean up your cables i'm
not trying to say it as some sort of
like uh when people point out oh small
legs you skip leg they bro it's more
like it's so easy to fix it and it makes
it look so much nicer i think at least
the desk i'll go from left to right but
it looks really clean i do like it he's
got that taste for red
red and black it always looks good
fine got connoisseur of the aesthetic
over here i'm really
jealous of his desk because it's
obviously huge
one thing with my setup is i wish i had
space you can see in the mirror
i wish i had space for speakers because
i i love music i don't know if you guys
knew this about me
it's kind of a quirky trait i have no
but i i i love good speakers it's
something uh something really i i i
wouldn't mind spending money on but i i
don't know how to fit it in here so [ __ ]
it i bought these speakers for japan
they're insane they cost more than my
car
it's the dumbest thing i ever bought but
i'm so and i can't even [ __ ] use it
god damn it guy hate everything yeah
you're gonna talk about the cables
the mac pro which is the uh
decade i've had it
you're not going to say anything about
that
pokemon you know we've only reacted to
jesus christ how do you even get that
many i'm not seeing dan and this now i'm
just impressed how she got so many
[ __ ] cables jesus christ
holy [ __ ]
oh god
what else we can check out what is this
memory seven something different one
that looks good god i love some colored
shelves man
my uh street oh well that's a bit
disappointing anymore i'm becoming a
professional streamer guys that's good
in it obviously i've got my stream deck
still i had this last time i don't like
the stream deck that much i never use it
go xlr they have it
yeah
i don't i'm sorry bro i don't really
like it
how many displays does he have four she
says for this place to play among us oh
i'm sorry you're at the bottom dude you
had me with the collared shelves so i'm
not gonna lie i expected more you said
it you set it up to fail we got lazy hey
welcome to the laser beam office he has
a fake pewdiepie mouse get the hell out
of here keyboards because i have two
computers prepare to be flexed on this
thing is legitimately the sexiest thing
in my life it has a 30 90.
uh-huh it looks like a really nice
studio other than that you're not
getting many points from me buddy i'm
sorry all right let me also quickly
judge some of you guys set up okay so i
posted on instagram uh that you guys
should post your site i'm not really
curious what's gonna show up
semen minimalist
mess specs fun part
what's minimalist about it elaborate
okay
at least you have some morgan
enjoy the superior cable management
oh we got the lava lamp nice gotta have
the lava lamp that's probably pretty
cozy to be fair that looks nice that
looks neat clean i like it look okay
it's for pewdiepie leave me alone
uh bro
i feel like this is a
a very typical
gamer guy setup right here we got the
leds in the in the ceiling
nothing wrong with that obviously way
too many monitors and cables going
everywhere rgbs with no
real aesthetic it seems
don't be mean it's i'm like i'd be
[ __ ] stoked to have this set up it's
a nice setup you can move things around
know i don't know this looks clean as
hell nice i like that uh you're
purposely not showing any of the cables
i like that as well we got the same
pretty similar similar desk similar mic
green that looks clean
very nice dude it's really fun to see
this [ __ ] that looks hella nice dude is
that yours for real
i like it
it's always nice getting the
the display off the desk i feel like
that makes such a difference hell yeah
based sometimes all you need is a laptop
that was cozy holy sh is that actually
is that like a bitcoin mining ship what
is happening bro floor gang
respect it love that [ __ ] hell yeah oh
delete this box out
delete this now go keyboard i like these
new cases that people have they're
really a lot of glass it's cool to see
it i actually like it that looks hella
clean my dude oh bro see this is typical
guys set up like bro what a mess dude
it's nice don't get me wrong but bruh
come on oh that's cool see again just
putting the displays off the ground
makes it already like so much better i
think that looks super cozy that looks
[ __ ] aesthetic dude kind of like it
what the [ __ ] some cyberpunk feel to it
i don't know why
and then you have the linus tech tips
which kind of
that's so cozy still working progress
hey surprising lack of pewdiepie chairs
here what the actual [ __ ] is happening
this is not your setup dude
get the hell out of here
[Laughter]
that looks sick dude very cozy i like it
that also looks epic well done bro all
right we got some really neat stuff and
then you have this
fair enough
can we hook up well chillas clutch
chairs can we hook her up and get her a
chair
please
no one should sit on that no one all
right let's go on with the tour
welcome to my setup tour come on in
yeah
that's too close
looking cozy
yeah
it's not the best setup in the world but
it's my setup and i like it okay seeing
how harsh i've been on other people's
tours i kind of feel like i've set
myself up to failure but
let's get started what do you start with
the essentials the computer
can you see it
it's got the brofist logo swerving
animation that's how you know it's a
good computer
yeah
it's got the red theme on it
the rgb that's how you know you're a
gamer get it from here yeah
it's a good computer i feel like uh you
could have way better computers and
you've seen me play minecraft and it's
really on his last breath playing
minecraft
with shaders and all that stuff
but uh
we're moving to japan i'm not gonna buy
another computer ship it all the way
over there oh my god for context how
long we've waited to go to japan and
linus tech tip sent me his the creeper
computer right he sent that to japan
first yeah they actually sent it back
because we weren't there to take it it's
not crazy
that's how long it's been anyway uh i
like i like the computer it's good it's
a good computer okay i have the specs
it's a 64 gigabyte intel core
i
something
well now you're just showing all of my i
don't know
it's fine
um yeah you don't you know considering i
started making videos on like you know
an hp laptop that was garbage i feel
good with this one
uh got this huge display which i like
it's a
samsung
i really like it and i put it on like a
don't worry it makes that sound
what are these called arm so you can
move it bling it move
flip over your stuff
you want to stand up you sit down
whatever
it's very comfortable especially when
streaming and stuff like that you can
just
yeah
everyone has like three monitors right
and then it's all look one
just one
better one better one good
one great i should probably know like
what i have
i have an re 320 microphone
yeah
it sounds great i love this microphone
uh i've used a lot of different ones in
the past but i think this one is the one
that i like the most especially because
you guys are usually over there
and it doesn't cover up all my face i
feel like a lot of youtubers
they do like this they have like the
camera there and it's like hi guys
here's me i'm like it sounds great but
it looks stupid not calling anyone out
it's not like mine my stuff is the best
but you know how it is
what is the best however i will tell you
it's the pewdiepie keyboard
look at this baby let's turn down the
brightness here a little bit
looking hella sexy
and the pewdiepie mouse of course
doesn't get better than this
we even got the pewdiepie cable baby
yeah
i don't like the free pie
mouse pad
because i prefer this one
it's too dark
there we go can you see better now
well you gotta see the rgbs you know
the camera i use is a sony a7 you just
pretend it's there basically a7 3s i
really like this camera because it's um
i can double it as for photography if
we're going out traveling i can use it
to take pictures i used to have an old
sony a7 no one cares but they were such
i had so much problem with them they
would turn themselves off randomly and
like plugging them into the computer
would give all kinds of issues but now
they work amazingly you just plug it in
it works i love that camera everyone's
complaining about my camera quality for
so long i'm so glad i finally fixed it
like it's an expensive camera but it's
super good
uh and i love using it it's plug and
play basically you plug it in with like
a fake battery and hdmi cable and that's
all it needs you could even just use one
cable for it but
i also have this which is very
unnecessary but it's basically like my
top cam which is nice when i'm streaming
or if i do branded stuff i can just show
very easily as an epic minimalist it's
kind of hard to justify having like
something that's so completely
unnecessary but it's nice and it's not
it's not in the way you know it's never
a problem it's just there which i like i
guess that's the whole thing but i want
to keep it simple i want to keep minimal
i don't like having a lot of [ __ ] i
don't like having cables i hate cables
they're the devil
uh but some cables you gotta have like
charging your phone or plugging your
phone into the computer and stuff like
that and some stuff you know i like to
have just because it's a fun memory like
this we bought in hakone do you remember
that
the
art what is that called
open art museum which i recommend check
it out if you're ever in hakone you know
small stuff too like i need my remote
for the ac
not on the dance this has to be clean
baby i even put this now you want
fisherman fan bro
you know what all right well another
thing
i got in my head that i needed which i
don't need which is this which i use as
a sound board i don't need it i don't
need it that was a mistake i recognized
that but now i may gone through only
effort putting it in anyway got the most
comfortable chair in the game
3.99 i don't think it's 3.99 anymore
it's like 420 or something
i'm sorry i use the elgato light
thanks to pokey who pointed out not to
put it in my face it now points toward
the light at the wall the light points
towards the wall
is this interesting does anyone give a
[ __ ]
[Music]
might say it's so bored are you feeling
a gay oh that's so cute
he's actually using it normally uh so
many times he's just sleeping there and
i'm like are you kidding me oh now we
get to dig deep this is the fun stuff
this is where the fun begins look at
this no messy cables mabels
everyone okay there are some cables i
acknowledge that okay but no messes
messy cables okay got only necessary so
microphone goes here
underneath plops up here into this into
the audio interface which then goes to
my computer check this out
hidden underneath baby that's how it's
done i don't want to see it
i actually use usually used to have like
a little box like that one over there
yeah whatever i used to have it here but
now i know and you know now i have all
these extra space where i can you can do
this if i want i couldn't do that before
you feel me my butt
um so yeah all the cables come from here
let me go in there
and go my computer it did 10 bucks 10
bucks and some schmucks and you got a
decent looking cable situation it's not
the best i get it but it's pretty
goddamn good
oh god
demon creatures
okay when we moved here how long it
would go was that 2014 2013 we realized
very quickly how bad the internet was
like i had that like 0.16 megabit upload
it would take a whole day to upload a
video
so i went to a company and they give you
like this special internet it's like a
company internet whatever they said it
was gonna take like 30 days to install
they took like six months it was
ridiculous they come here they slap this
thing on the wall like boom i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that and then they had
they used to have like cables coming all
over and and check this out check this
out
do you hear that
they just put this here right it's like
it pisses me off
so i managed to drill and put it all so
the cables are hidden and whatever i
don't have to hear it but i can't
believe
those [ __ ] they came here and just
put it there
can you believe it
30 days they say i pay like 200 a month
for the internet it's ridiculous but
whatever i need it and now it's good
this is uh where i crawl in i don't know
how i used to fit in here
how do i fit in here
i wouldn't fit in here anymore
uh here's where i keep my
spare setup like if we ever travel like
we were in italy a few months ago
i got a laptop microphone audio
interface
basically everything i have here
in there
so if you ever need to go it might not
be portable we can do it which is cool
here is usually where i put like uh
stuff i buy for videos this is a
printing
who gives it no one anyway
uh this is actually kind of cool
i used to try to organize all my cables
and i try to make it nice but literally
you just get one of these
and you're good
which is also really good for
uh
if you travel because missing a cable
like if you're going somewhere
and you're in another country that's the
worst thing ever so
i don't know i think it's a cool
solution whatever it's a box who gives a
[ __ ] i give a [ __ ] okay i'm making this
video talking about it
that's not much else to say i think yeah
got all my lenses in here
that's it
got this camera so i can spy on we can
spy on the dogs
these were supposed to be in the
background of the video but now that i
moved my camera you can't really see it
but it's like stuff i really like like
the pewdiepie figurine is obviously
really cool
i love this figurine gary baseman
we have the terraria collab figurine
which is in the box it's going to be
worth a billion y'all you all will have
your stinky nfts
but you're going to wish you had the
pewdiepie terraria figurine idiots
it's also kind of like my charging place
here because i can hide all that
behind
ah
anyone remember this
no you don't because youtube deleted the
video but it's real it exists and it did
happen i have proof
this is so cool i love this door
it fits so well here too
i say that
uh what else do i have to show ikea
gundam
yeah
i'm so proud of the ikea gundam that was
like the first time i ever i'm not a
like a precise kind of person but with
with the gundam i was like i'm gonna do
it the best i could possibly do it and
it was more about not getting it done
more about enjoying the process which is
new for me so
yeah that was a fun thing i'm proud of
it which made me proud of it because i
tried my hardest even though it's just a
toy who cares got my beer headset which
i used to play i play golf with my
parents
it's so good it's so funny walk about
mini golf
due to the dynamic and not being able to
travel that was like a really fun nice
thing to do i'm glad i have that yeah
check out software stuff
also a godsend is having the ac there
because god damn having the lights on
and this screen and computer in one room
it can get hot as hell or cold so
i'm always comfortable here this is so
nice
software wise i'll link to my background
and stuff like that i'm using rainmaker
if you're wondering a lot of people ask
me about um
like these extensions
they're super useful you can put a timer
which i like if i'm
trying to study on the computer it's
nice to put a timer on yourself or
screenshots or volume but it's right
there i really like that
i use obs like everyone does because
it's just so goddamn good
when it wants to start and you know what
i do use bandicam still i don't give a
[ __ ] i use that again
it's so useful to like crop and just
pick a place to record i don't care what
anyone thinks about bandicam uh this is
how it looks like at least when i record
a video and then if i stream i should be
here but i'm not because i only have one
camera because i only need one camera
because i am an epic minimalist thank
you got all this different cool you know
how obs works no one cares it's very
simple when we started making videos
companies like elgato or gaming stuff
there were not any focus on or software
wise like everyone you you know it
doesn't matter no one gives a [ __ ]
it's just everything is so much better
now even like cameras like you wouldn't
be able to do stuff that you can do now
and it's very nice i like it
i love this setup it feels really good
i can look at myself
this is how i spend most of my days just
sitting
i just sit here and i think about
what i do and
what am i doing with my life
i'm just sitting here
[Music]
thinking
what
might say i didn't show the led lights
might come back
i didn't show the led lights
there you go
you see that it lits up
it's red
it's like a theme it's like a theme i
have rate my setup do it in the comments
so yeah that's my setup tour if you
enjoyed smash like subscribe smash like
subscribe smash like subscribe smash
like subscribe smash like subscribe
smash like subscribe
it's my